let's say I have three chairs I'll just
make them like they'll just be blanks
one two and three three chairs and I
have seven people I'll call them four
people a b c d e how many is that that's
five f G so we have seven people and
what I want to know is how many
different ways can these seven people
sit in these three chairs well before
anyone sits down if we just pick a chair
let's you know just art well arbitrary
these are just arbitrary labels for the
chairs but let's just start at the left
with chair number one if no one is
sitting down how many different people
could sit down in chair one well seven
people are standing up no one is sitting
in any of the chairs so seven different
people could sit in chair one so there
are seven possibilities for chair one so
one of those seven possibilities is
going to sit down and chair one so how
many people are left to sit in chair two
well one less than seven right six
people are going to be left to sit in
chair two and then of course if two
people are already sitting down how many
people are left to sit in chair treat
the chair three well there's going to be
five possibilities so we're to think
about it for each of these possibilities
there are six possibilities in this
chair and five possibilities in that
chair for each of those six so you would
multiply all of the possibilities
hopefully that makes some sense well
we'll try it out with some examples so
the total number of possibilities in
this case is 7 times 6 times 5 and what
is that 6 times 5 is 30 30 times 7 it
equals 210 there's 210 possibilities
that's that's a lot of possibilities
let's do a slightly smaller example
let's say I mean we don't have to do
people in chairs let's say we have cups
yeah sure let's say we have cups and let
me I'll do the cups in a different color
so this is one cup cup one and then I
have cup two and then I have three balls
I have a magenta ball I have
Brown ball and I have a yellow ball and
I want to know how many different ways
can I put these three balls into these
two cups well assuming that I haven't
put any of the balls into any of the
cups is yet how many balls we'll just
start with with with cup - I just want
to show you that I'm you know you don't
have to start cup the cup that happens
to be labeled number one and it's
sitting on the left so if we haven't put
if we haven't put any balls into any of
the cups
how many can be put in cup - well
there's three possibilities right and
for each of those three then how many
can we put into cup one well we would
have put one into here so there'll be
two left to put into Cup - so be three
times two possibilities which is equal
to six and let's see if we can if we can
draw them out with well let me let me
number these cups because it's going to
be too too too difficult to keep
switching colors so let's say this is a
B and C I'm going to show you that there
are six ways of putting these three cups
into these these three balls into these
two cups
so let's could be a and cup one B and
Cup - it could be B and Cup one in Cup -
right you can just switch them so we
actually care which ball goes into wet
cop not just you know it's ball in a cup
it could be a let's see in Cup one C in
cup to BC in cup one n cop - and then
finally you could just have B and C B in
cup one seeing cup two or C in Cup one B
in cup two and notice that if we didn't
care if we just cared which of the balls
were picked but we didn't you know we
didn't care whether there were a couple
in our Cup - we could get rid of this
bottom line and there would be there
would be half as many ways to place them
but when we care where where the balls
are right we care whether they're in cup
1 or cup 2 or in this case we care if
they're in seat one two or three the
ways in which we're ordering we call
these permutations and up here the way
we would write this permutation we would
say well how many ways can we fit
seven people into three chairs if we
care about what chair they're sitting in
so we could write that as seven from
people and the P isn't for people it's
for permutations into three chairs and
another notation for it you write a big
P and you say how many ways can I put
seven things into three spaces or it
could be written as how many ways could
you put seven things into three spaces
and in this case we got the answers to
ten and actually it will always be to
ten and I'll show you why in a second
and how would we write this well this
would be I'll do it in green because we
it was we had three things and we put it
into two spaces so three things into two
spaces and that's the same thing as
three things into two spaces which is
equal to three things into two spaces
I'm just showing you the different
notations and we figured out that that
was six let's see if we can figure out a
general formula if we if we wanted to
evaluate you know n P K how many ways
can we fit n things into K into K spaces
right so if we think about it you know
we're going to have let's just use some
analogy will have K spots so it'll be
you know one spot two spots three spots
all the way to K spots right in the
first spot there's n possibilities just
like we did in the last two examples
there's n possibilities there then since
one person or one thing will be placed
in spot one there's going to be n minus
1 possibilities for spot 2 and similarly
n minus two possibilities for spot 3 and
then we could follow that pattern all
the way and how many possibilities are
there going to be for spot K well in
everything it's n minus 1 thing less
than the spot number in our case I mean
I guess we could have started what spot
zero but this is better because we
actually numbered all the way to K so it
will be n
- K - 1 right and that might seem
complicated but it makes sense like it
when we did you know seven things into
three into three spots we went seven
times six times we literally put in the
top three of you can almost say from the
factorial right seven factor will be 7
times 6 times 5 I think this will help
you know if this was just 3 it was 7
times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 that's 7 factorial but we only
took the first three of the factorial
and similarly 6 well 6 is also 3
factorial but another way you could view
it is only took we only took the first 2
of 3 factorial so what we're saying here
is we just take the first K of n
factorial so is there any easy way to
write that to write the first K first K
of n factorial well sure we could write
it as n factorial and the formula is
almost harder than what it's saying we
could write it as n factorial with a
lowercase n and factorial over n minus K
factorial let's see if that works
well what's going to happen so in this
case we n factorial was 7 so it's 7
times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1
and then what was n minus K factorial
well in our example K was the number of
spots and there were 3 spots so 7 minus
3 is 4 so 4 factorial it's 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 and of course this will
cancel let me do it in a different color
this will cancel with this and so you're
just left with the first 3 of 7
factorial or you know the 3 largest
components of 7 of 7 factorial I often I
always read arrive this because all I
think of is what we did originally as a
okay if we're doing permutations the
first but you know I just I just start
the factorial until I run out of spots
so I do 7 times 6 times 5 and let's see
if it works out here too so what is 3
factorial because we have 3 different
things 3 factorial over and then 3 minus
2 factorial right 3 minus 2 backdoor
well that's just 1 factorial right so it
becomes 3 times 2 times 1 over 1 and of
course the ones cancel out and we got
the 3 times 2 hopefully that makes sense
a lot of people they just you know they
just they learn the permutation notation
and they say oh that's n factorial over
n minus K factorial where n is the
number of things I need to place and K n
minus this whole thing factorial and K
is the number of spots I have and they
just memorize it but all this is saying
is you start you know almost just you
know multiply doing the N factorial but
you only do the first 3 components of
the factorial and it makes sense just
from how we started off the video if you
have seven things well seven things
could go here six things go here five
things could go here no more spots just
multiply them and that's all this
formula is saying hopefully I didn't
confuse you and I will see you in the
next video on combinations